Professor Luciano floridi is the Oxford
internet institute's professor of
philosophy and ethics of information at
the University of Oxford where he's also
the director of the digital ethics lab
of the Oxford internet Institute still
in Oxford he's a distinguished research
fellow of the uhiro center for practical
ethics of the faculty of philosophy and
research associate and fellow in
information policy in the department of
computer science
outside Oxford he's the faculty fellow
of the Alan Turing Institute and chair
of its data ethics group and the
distinguished scholar in Residence of
the Department of Economics at the
American University in Washington DC his
research concerns primarily digital
ethics the philosophy of information
which is a discipline he founded and the
philosophy of Technology itself I will
introduce it AI as a divorce between the
ability to perform a task successfully
in view of a goal shall we say play
chess just to be trivial and any need to
be intelligent in doing so
replace that with
parking a car Landing an aircraft
delivering something to your house
you don't have to be intelligent to do
that if you are a piece of AI That's why
it works
if you had to wait to be intelligent you
would
my iPhone there turned off properly
would not play a better chance than
anyone else in this room if we had to
wait for that iPhone to be as
intelligent as a rat it is because it
isn't and we gave up on trying to make
it intelligent as a rat
we're in the midst of an information
revolution as well as a Computing
Revolution
Florida said in his introductory book
that all members of the G7 qualify as
information societies because in each
country at least 70 percent of their GDP
depends on intangible goods which are
information related not on material
Goods their functioning and growth
requires and generates immense amounts
of data more data than Humanity has ever
seen in its entire history it was
estimated in 2003 that Humanity had
accumulated approximately 12 exabytes of
data and we're fast approaching the age
of the zettabytes which is 1 000
exabytes sometimes people think in terms
of oh can we regulate AI which is a bit
like can we regulate electricity well
it's a bit big what do you mean it's not
true false correct incorrect it just
doesn't yet make any friction with the
real world
floridi thinks that the material world
is becoming redundant our agency as
humans is being perniciously eroded and
that the increasing dominance of the
information landscape or the infosphere
as floridi calls it is becoming the
primary basis for our reality
now about 95 of all of the data that we
have today has been created by the
current generation we're not talking
about Shakespeare or Dante we're talking
about lots and lots of dogs and cats
floridi thinks that the infosphere is
becoming so polluted with every passing
day that the manifold of the infosphere
is increasingly determined by technology
and artificial intelligence people are
consumers consumers become followers
followers become barcodes increasingly
the data is stored in a representation
which is primarily machine readable
designed for consumption by other
machines our very existence is being
squeezed as a result
but wouldn't be great to have something
instead of us doing it for us better
than us
yeah absolutely
um I mean if you read the description of
that something that does it instead of
us better than us
in Aristotle
is a Slave
that's what we could do in the past
who's horrible luckily it's not
happening around us but we were using
humans as means to an end
now we can use technology
why this divorce why sort of putting
pulling apart and saying look I want to
develop something that's successful I
don't care whether it does it in the
same way as I do it as long as
successful is fine as opposed to you
know I want to implement human cognition
and if it's not human cognition I don't
care what he's successful or not but he
has to have a little spark now remember
no AI is an engineering Branch or is a
branch of colony science well as a
branch of colony science we are at ear
zero no step forward we do not have the
intelligence as I said of a rat
when it comes to engineering
that looks like magic
that looks like what has happened to
humanity who has given us so much brain
to do what we're doing today
and the old phrase like
is it worth asking whether a submarine
can swim
really can a computer think Ah that's
the wrong question that's not the
framework within which we should
understand what a computer does a
submarine does what he does an airplane
does what he does and he doesn't do it
like a bird doesn't do it like a fish
but it does it successfully and that's
the whole engineering Point here success
in delivering the output given that
particular input but how do you know
it's not the same process well imagine
you have two two four and I tell you one
is plus the other one is multiplication
which one did I use to get four from two
and two I don't know two plus two is
equal four two by two is four you see
you can't say so it's the same thing no
it isn't
the way I do the dishes the way my
dishwasher done the dishes two different
things
floridi said something very significant
and profound has recently happened to
Human self-understanding
he said that in many respects we're not
Standalone entities but rather
interconnected informational organisms
or info orgs sharing with biological
agents and engineered artifacts a global
environment ultimately made of
information what floridi calls the
infosphere
this is the informational environment
constituted by all the informational
processes services and entities thus
including the informational agents as
well as their properties and
interactions and mutual relations
now if there was a representative
scientist for the fourth Revolution this
would definitely be Alan Turing it's now
critical that we equip ourselves with a
viable philosophy of information
yeah of any kind of any sort an old
digital readable machine readable when I
mean Machinery but they're barcodes not
meant for our eyes they are meant for
the machines if you hear anything about
the natives the natives in this space
are the robots not us who scuba die
but these machines they are digital
elements in the digital environment
reading digital stuff and digital
processing
Etc
and of course I show you better machine
learning better algorithms but also more
and more internal things things
connected to other things and when you
go home and you see all those green and
blue lights
they're not for us they're talking to
each other
and a lot of the data we have are
generated by those machines
information and communication
technologies have been changing the
world profoundly and irreversibly for
more than half a century now with
breathtaking scope and at neck breaking
Pace on the one hand they've brought
concrete and imminent opportunities of
enormous benefit to people's education
welfare and prosperity as well as great
economic and scientific advantages
this merging of our existence both
analog and digital both online and
offline I would really ever offline of
course not so I'm reminded normally that
if you have ever heard the whale singing
if you don't even know what I'm talking
about then you're very very young but if
you know what I'm talking about then you
have use something called a modem
that is called whale singing and if you
have heard the whale singing well you're
more like on my side of the Divide so we
don't hear the whale singing anymore
floridi thinks that the risks are the
nature of reality and our knowledge of
it the organization of a fair Society
considering the digital divide are
responsibilities and obligations to
present and future Generations our
understanding of a global world and the
scope of our potential interactions with
the environment and finally conceptual
implications and complexity of an
information and communication technology
landscape so we don't hear the way of
singing anymore there is no Terminator
coming there is no gods in the sky
deciding for us there's nobody but
Humanity responsibility for what we're
going to do with this technology and
anyone disagrees I hope it's just naive
and doesn't have an agenda
floridi said that the Information
Society has grown quickly and
chaotically leading to a lack of balance
between technological growth and a lack
of understanding of the implications of
this growth
it also highlights the need to dig
deeper into the nature and implications
of the information age in order to
better anticipate and identify and
resolve problems
we started understanding ourselves
in roughly in two ways who I am and what
I can do I am not Humanity speaking
different exceptional well special
because of my nature and because and or
what I can do compared to anything else
so one is called
personal identity is Gonna Come Close to
privacy
and the gazillions of data out there are
eroding or transforming exercising
pressure on their particular who I am my
nature my data subject as we are defined
by the European legislation you know we
all data subjects here gdpr generator
protection regulation uh says so so if
your data subject and there's a
convenience of data about you somewhere
being manipulated well certainly your
identity is no shall we say uh in
question
the other half is remember not who I am
but what I can do as opposed to anyone
else but I say I and we Define ourselves
at least since can't always imagine the
German philosophy in terms of autonomy
we are special because we are in control
of our actions we can decide we can plan
we can choose well now we have
autonomous agents out there
and if you're trying to identify
yourself as we can only be no the one
Supply chains well then we are really in
trouble you can devalue human skills you
can remove human responsibility you can
reduce human control erode human
self-determination is the other side of
the coin it's not super dangerous
but
The Rock who thoughts that their little
drop or water
was nothing
18 years later has a big hole in it
because drop after drop after drop the
drop Will shape the stone will shape The
Rock
surely want to have a technology that
makes us more capable of deciding what
we want
or prefer what we really
have in front of us
and I'm a bit worried that here human
nature no we philosophers we know
something about human nature we'll kick
in
uh we're lazy
we're also very malleable
and we are easily convinced
to do this or that
so we need to be a little bit more
careful exposing this very fragile
malleable entity to a very robust
quite silly very efficient
very successful
technology there will probably tend to
inadvertently change the nature of that
fragile entity this is something that I
would like to be a little bit more
concerned about not Terminator
so until recently you would go to now
this wonderful techie uh conferences and
it was all about Technology Innovation
the average
politician salivates immediately as soon
as you talk about Innovation because
Innovation is growth growth is money
money is jobs and people are happy so
Innovation Innovation yeah absolutely
and it's crucial but it's not real
challenge I don't think that that's the
most difficult challenge we are facing
now not because it's easy but because
something more difficult to do behind
Innovation the challenge therefore is
how you govern all this but governance
is a matter of design
designing the right policies so that the
incentives and the disincentives are in
the right place there are no loopholes
people tend to do more the writing than
the bad thing so all of a sudden we are
shifting all this into socio-political
issues
as a matter of design design the kind of
society we want remember what's the
human project here that we want to
implement
so anyway I had a very fun trip up to
Oxford the other day and had a chat with
Luciano himself I hope you find this
episode valuable remember to subscribe
and uh if you're listening give us a
rating on Apple podcasts or or whatever
you listen to the podcast on
enjoy
so um to start proceedings off with
misinformation
um the internet has put the world in our
pocket knowledge at our fingertips uh
but um the business of the internet is
about ads and exploitation uh debasement
and derangement of human attention and
some have argued that social media is a
bit like the climate change of our
society are you concerned that the
current state of Internet economics will
create a layer of plausible yet false
abstraction between us and reality
there's that risk and there's a risk of
um more and more content uh being
worthless uh unreliable false misleading
uh fake news propaganda
it is not a new problem but the size the
immensity the impact is new
here it's one thing if you publish a few
pamphlets with several eyes and another
thing if you have uh hundreds or
millions of followers believing at once
uh that something was not the case and
something that was the case wasn't uh
and I'm talking about elections and uh
not very public figures
I wouldn't however uh put the whole
emphasis on the negative side the social
media are also if we want the solution
to the problem today are part of the
problem I agree but they could easily
become part of the solution precisely
because then if you remember and I close
here uh good old days when we were
online and there was no web only the
internet
we thought that we were going to create
a more informed more civilized more
reasonable uh environment
we can still do that
um it's the kind of business models and
lack of political legal framework that
has generated this tsunami of
Jose rubbish which is uh polluting our
infosphere the space of our information
so yes it is a problem uh no it doesn't
have to be a problem it could be easily
a big solution
one suggestion for all and let's close
here imagine if we were to ban and it's
a bit of a joke advertisement online
who would have to pay we would pay for
the product that meant that there will
become competition for Quality it will
be probably in a different kind of game
interesting and we'll get into a minute
uh we'll get into the subject of how the
the structures of let's say uh markets
and and economic models affect us
um you know as as human beings and as a
society but also affects our
um perception of of reality essentially
but before we get there um you wrote a
paper uh called gpt3 it's nature Scopes
limits and consequences and um you said
that reversible and irreversible
questions are based on mathematical
logic
um lib in its law and and other fields
such as Computing and physics can you
explain what you meant by that
it's a simple idea so uh if I fail it's
my fault
um
a question that I I Define there as
reversible means that from the answer
you can reverse to the actual identity
of the source of the answer
an irreversible one is one that doesn't
allow you to do that let me give you an
irreversible answer today come to my
house you find clean dishes on the table
who has cleaned the dishes it's
irreversible you can't tell it could be
me or it could be the dishwasher so you
cannot tell by looking at the dishes the
output whether those dishes have gone
through a process of hand washing or
machine washing and whether the source
is one or the other
a reversible one would be the sort of
question that today and I'm talking
today we can ask to chat GPT nah
use uh anything like Mary's mother has
three children tell me the name of one
of them ngpt says I don't know it does I
have no enough information he said oh
it's Mary's mother so surely
um so that becomes immediately
reversible you know exactly that the
answer is coming from a computer from a
large
Model A large language model uh and not
from a human being who gets that
immediately
imagine the other way around he asked
for a super complex calculation and boom
you get the answer in a fraction of a
second the other one is make a mistake
maybe it takes longer side no who was
the other side uh so increasingly in the
paper I write that
um and it was before chat GPT coming out
but it's obvious and it's been not our
progress since then increasingly the
sort of output that we are dealing with
will become irreversible we will be
unable to tell whether the source is for
example a human being a group of human
being a human being with a computer or
chat gbt or whatever is going to come a
gpt4 etc imagine GPT 10. no not many
years from now
um I think that it will be completely
irreversible it does not mean however
let me close here that I'm like the
dishwasher if you can't tell who did the
dishes
what difference does he make I've done
them in one way which is completely
different uh uh the machine does it in a
sort of mechanical Etc so we should be
clear about what we infer from the
reversibility any reversibility of the
output and that seems to me where a lot
of confusion is generated interesting so
there's the provenance of the
information so where it originated from
we could go down the line of saying
because it is human aligned with this
reinforcement learning for human
feedback it's remarkably human aligned
actually much more than the original
gpt3 and then he spoke to this somatic
as a semantic Divergence and and we can
talk about the pragmatic Divergence as
well and actually that that's getting
into a little bit about what um John so
talked about you know the difference
between ontology and and epistemology
um is is that something that that you're
seriously concerned about I mean could
you expand on that
uh I am concerned about it and I'm one
of the few people I hope um many more
than that it seems uh uh who agree with
the with the Chinese room and uh the the
philosophy behind it of course you can
always no among philanthru is going to
always argue for details and
sophisticated come to agriculture but
the bottom line I mean John got it uh
right a long time ago uh we're dealing
with syntactic engines there is no
understanding there is no insight there
is no emotional involved Etc anything
that would go into qualifying
characterizing human intelligence which
is also a rather fuzzy concept by the
way
so on that front I think we're going to
see more and more of successful machines
um of the kind that we were just
discussing
you mentioned the source because that is
the real difference
um let me give you a small example uh
suppose you take uh uh from
the Shelf
an amazing novel a novel that has done
on the Nobel for example
I would be surprised if you were too
confused that for something that's been
generated by GPT X
the other thing is not true suppose you
take a normal text like an encyclopedia
entry or a good summary of that novel
would you be able to tell me whether
he's a human being or gptx you wouldn't
so there's also asymmetry between the
sort of product that we get in a sort of
uh inferences that we can run
final point you know you
technically is not everything and we
always fall into the same trap you see
someone
reproducing on
the pavement in a street the Sistine
chap
it's amazing I mean I wish I could do
that but it's not Michelangelo why well
because there is a different history a
different uh intention there's a
different Aesthetics so the mere ability
of reproducing or doing like
fails to get the semantic Capital behind
all that the intention the
interpretation the historical context
the continuity the why did it happen and
did not happen something else uh all
that is the richness of our
understanding and semantics we lose that
if we think that all the difference that
there is between Michelangelo and the
artist in the street is just technique
it's not the case and we should not be
confused on that
I completely agree with you that there
is a rich semantic context which is
embedded and this is some this is
something I'm conflicted on so I agree
um with so
in the sense that he said there was this
rich in a Nagle actually this
impenetrable Realm of the subject of
experience and that informs the meaning
you know there's an ontological
difference in understanding which is
what what cell said but what's been so
remarkable with chat GPT is it does seem
to
um confer some semantic
um uh and sort of inference if you like
and I think the reason for that is going
back to Pierce's Triad the um the
symbolic
um uh version the you know the semantic
content is embedded in our language and
that's why gpt3 even though it's mimicry
it often appears to I mean for example
it knows what the concept of Christmas
is
so now it's becoming such a close
reflection of us it's becoming more
difficult to distinguish
oh and at some point it would be
impossible if not already
but we should be careful uh not to
confuse this with um
what you mentioned before the
intentionality the real meaning of
existential
um experience of all this uh Christmas
is something that
reverberates and and provides meaning
for example in each of us for a reason
that is utterly cultural uh it would
have meant nothing to Plato obviously
for historical reasons and so on let me
give an example this will be like saying
that when you cut the tree and you find
the rings of the tree uh telling the age
of the tree the tree somehow told us its
age
well I think that takes a little bit of
imagination no it did not
um and yet the symbolic the the
representational it is true that the
tree has provided that information to
begin with but it's also because we can
interpret that way so
I would like to see more work done on
the hermeneutical side of all this so
that we get
clear on what we are consuming uh
content which is
sometimes impeccable sometimes
irreversible cannot be distinguished
from content that could have been
produced by a human being but also the
understanding the interpretation the
context the why it matters of their
content now boilerplates are exactly
what they are
and if there's something in a for
example uh encyclopedia entry or in a
Wikipedia entry that matters is exactly
is objectivity is luck in so far as we
can do that of interpretation of an
angle yeah almost like as if the author
had to disappear
but that is exactly where
tools like GPT number uh will excel
it will be different if we were talking
about the way in which an artist a
writer or anyone
simply putting notes any hair on Diaries
is going through the process of
verbalizing conceptualizing The
Experience Etc so ultimately uh it'll
allow me another analogy there's a
reason why although we could have the
best director and the best orchestra
performing that particular concert in
the hall it's just a recording that you
had to play we don't and we can't get a
few a bunch of kids in a choir and a few
people who are rather amateurish here in
Oxford and do a good job but certainly
not as good as it could have been done
by now professionals is The Human
Experience that matters it doesn't
matter whether you could do that better
by having a tool
given the pollution of the infosphere
with data generated from large language
models what are the ethical implications
on society
they are quite enormous I mean the
responsibility uh uh on so many fronts
um this responsibility of course of the
source of dispolution and by the way
um we know that the actual sources are
not many uh it's not that each of us is
constantly pouring sort of providing
extra bits of uh misleading information
in life we do inadvertently repeat and
and reverberate that but the actual
sources of say for example
um Russian propaganda are very few and
well-known
um
and likewise and on or many other
contexts so first of all a huge
responsibility on those who are uh
polluting the environment there are few
they're powerful and uh they should be
um
cursailed uh shall we say uh if not
entirely stopped huge responsibility on
people who could legislate much better
and more uh firmly uh look at the
current debate and uh you know people
listening to this and watching this
should look at the date but look at
what's happening these days uh to
Twitter I mean the debate is open about
not whether it's going to be a source of
information or misinformation and who
should be there or shouldn't Etc how
much do we want to control how much we
want to not filter but there's also how
our responsibility as a society we
should demand more and we should be more
careful so if we put together all these
responsibilities between the producers
those who take advantage of it the
consumers we are all in on this
um no wonder it's a mess but as I said
at the beginning we could rectify it
with a bit of Goodwill
now you wrote an article in in uh in
aeon a few years back called should we
be afraid of AI and the wrist debate has
been ongoing since the 1960s When Irvin
John good prophesied a potential
intelligence explosion uh that could
leave Humanity behind and on one side
are those who believe in true AI the
Church of the singularitarians as as you
uh wonderfully described them and on the
other side you have those who do not
believe in true AI known as the Church
of the atheists but spell AI which is uh
which is
um absolutely delicious and you said we
should remain tolerant of both views but
the real challenge is to ensure that AI
is used in a way that does not undermine
human dignity and you said the dogma of
the singularitarians consists of three
beliefs uh the creation of some form of
AI is likely and Humanity will be
dominated by it and it's the
responsibility of the current generation
to ensure it's benign
um so uh you said that uh
singularitarianism is is implausible it
relies on weak senses um of the
possibility
um of of um of possibility and Moore's
Law And it distracts from the real evils
it's almost an Indulgence of the um of
the western Elite so what can be done to
ensure that singularitarianism is is not
a distraction
I'm afraid that uh the only cure there
will be history uh meaning that um as we
move on
um we will see that AI in in its variety
of forms non-natural language processing
um robots
um even little gadgets that can help us
to do this and that uh in in our mobile
phone I mean they improve say
communication or enable us to take a
better picture uh the recommended
systems that you find on Netflix Etc um
and all these things we will see as we
uh move on and grow up that um
what has really happened is is
absolutely extraordinary but not
extraordinary as the single Italian uh
think uh it is we're actually separating
uh and increasingly so the ability to to
do these things and to to solve problems
take care of tasks successfully in view
of some goal some end from any need to
be intelligent in doing so that is
extraordinary this divorce between
agency and intelligence that is amazing
and if anyone doesn't want to speculate
just think about Chess playing I mean
chess playing today is done at serial
intelligence at least I hope people will
admit that my iPhone does doesn't think
and he beats anyone
I can encounter um
so extraordinary ability that would
require intelligence if I were to play
that way I wish I could but that it can
be done as your intelligence now
as we learn more and more that that is
the the Delta the Gap that we are
building and these two things will go
further and further not away as we move
on things in terms of what we just said
in terms of a large language models GPT
and the other ones there quick following
from other companies without advertising
for anyone
um we will find uh any uh Singularity
narrative uh science fiction I mean uh
entertaining uh at some point
um frustrating at others because um as
you said it is also distracting we have
plenty of problems generated by this
divorce if you have an enormous new
forest or source of agency in the world
at zero intelligence that requires
intelligence hours governance law ethics
a sense of what is the human project you
want to build and meanwhile you're
worried that you know your your car
would run away with your not credit card
to have a holiday on on a beach well
then certainly you know frustration
starts building up because we're not
taking care of the real issues now the
Discrimination the digital uh divide uh
the amount of things that we're not
doing no sort of our opportunity cost
wherever we are lacking a clear
framework and so on so Singularity I
mean like all churches I think they will
become increasingly old and they will
not die I mean they will always have a
few faithful ones but hopefully will not
be in the headlines which is one of the
reasons why people like to not push
forward the singularity so that they get
the headlines
in in terms of the end game though you
you might argue that they have
appointment I suppose you're you're
arguing that I don't want to put words
in your mouth but you just spoke about
the industrialized attenuation of our
agency and that maybe that's analogous
to saying we're becoming increasingly
enslaved by technology and our
children's generation much more so than
we are so
in some sense would you argue oh no like
saying well I mean you could read that
in terms of uh the the engine and and
wonder whether the engine and the the
old Industrial Revolution and
urbanization coming say from model uh
engine and and so on has been liberating
has been enslaving has been a good thing
a better thing uh has all real
historical and real philosophical issues
it's a mixed bag and you can't simply
say oh no I wish the the car had never
been invented really like I'm not quite
sure but on the other hand the damage
that we are caused to this environment
so same with the AI no one could say I
wish people had never taken this Genie
out of the particular bottle really like
the kind of things that we can do thanks
to this and I think of one case for just
just a simple case like uh called Fusion
I mean today if there's even a remote
chance
to get there is because of machine
learning we will never get there uh
without the enormous abilities of
computational problem solving provided
by Ai and so forth so this case too
requires more commitment
more as a human intelligence more
governance not less so sometimes I find
that debate it becomes a little bit of a
deterministic kind of uh debate between
things that not people who think they
were doomed and things to do you know
with no uh Rosy glasses think it was
going to be a Wonderful World well
honestly it just happened to us the
crude
painful sort of uh truth is that unless
we do something about it it will be a
mess but if we do something about it and
we do it rightly well then we can do an
enormous amount of good things for this
now and last point just to have some
references just look at uh you know the
impact of AI in a variety of forms again
on the uh sustainable development goals
has been already significant could do so
much more at the same time how much
energy goes into developing this uh sort
of large language models huge are we
really doing the best with this sort of
consumption and impact when then if we
were to use this for example for
entertainment for advertisement when
every bit of electricity out there
should be carefully considered
give an impact on the environment these
are real issues but they are
philosophical issues for human beings
is there a way that we can Embrace this
technology in a way that preserves human
dignity
I think so
um the question is not however to
simplify uh in terms of human-centric
because um uh my well reason maybe we
can explore later uh but we have done
too much of that precisely because we
have been so human-centric we have
destroyed this world we have killed the
environment we should be more sort of at
the service of
both the natural and the sort of
man-made
artificial environments as well so to me
the best way of using technology is by
respecting as we said before human
dignity but also using technology
to the benefit of quote unquote the
other which could be future Generations
it could be the environment it could
also be us taken as Humanity but not
just us if we use technology just for us
and our own benefit we will ignore a
future iterations we will ignore the
environment and we will not have done a
full decent job so yes there is but it
takes a little bit more of a commitment
than we have at the moment
what form of um governance do you
advocate for
to me the governance that we could
develop would inevitably leverage this
digital Revolution by offering not
imposing not expecting offering more
participation at the beginning of the
decision or process so these are two
distinctions that go against the red
democracy I'm not advocating for that
much I'm saying
offering so
cannot be expected or compulsory but
plenty of offer at the beginning not at
the end take the referendum uh painful
memory here we are in the UK um
a referendum is not the right democracy
why what because you can't choose
between you know A and B if you dislike
both A and B someone as prepared the
alternative for you the real democracy
that is co-designing of the choices not
the options at the end but the initial
choices is the one that says
should we consider a referendum
so the point here is that the earlier
the involvement
the better is to live in that kind of
society so the governance that I'm
advocating is is a governance that has
an as early as possible involvement of
people in a core design of the choices
that we face now that and I was here
sorry but it's a huge topic that uh
means that
behind the this this particular sort of
mechanism there is a separation between
those who have
power
the people and can delegate power and
those who exercise power but don't have
it this structural separation between
having power without exercising
an exercising power without having it
that to me is the ABC of any decent
governance governance fails especially
political governance no in a democratic
sense of governance fails the moment you
have those who have power exercises and
those who exercise that have it it
doesn't matter what is a majority is
minority is an oligarchy is three people
it's one person it's a family it's a
tyranny of a few people maybe only one
as soon as you separate this then we
start having the right governance then
we can talk about no involvement in the
decisional process as early as possible
then co-design and therefore for all
this the kind of technology that we have
this is doable if we want to implement
it
one thing that concerns me is that um
when we talk about the architectural
design of governance
the the structure can sometimes exclude
other parts of of the complex world that
we live in and also there's this
compatibility with the dmos which is to
say it needs to be intelligible and then
you have this problem of people voting
in their own self-interest even if they
did understand the the purpose of the
governance
true
um and and we know that self-interest
can go only that far we learned that
from the past Century no no the 20th
century the 20th century has been uh the
century especially the second half uh so
staff has been a disaster uh the second
half much more successful has been the
century of the the citizen consumer and
therefore the self-interest as a citizen
voting for not the best options making a
difference and therefore no competition
between different parties Etc and the
consumer having the same kind of choices
voting quote unquote with this no that
what they feed so to speak uh choosing
their restaurant or another their shop
rather another their product or another
but this
the figure that was the not selfish
interest
um consumer slash citizen has become not
the user
and the follower
so today instead of having citizens we
have sort of followers instead of having
consumers we have users and therefore
there's been a
impoverishment of precisely they're
selfish so interest the caring for my
individual project which is one of the
two legs for democracy
so their leg has become weak the other
leg is absent which is the social side
so at some point Society should also
invite facilitate support uh so nudge
gently towards more not social
solutions for the simple fact that if we
need to be more ambitious in our goals
we need to get together it's not enough
to not pursue our own self-interest we
have to pursue interest that are shared
so imagine the following picture out of
this quick analysis two legs one has
become weaker the selfish interest for
my individual project the other one
which is a social project is not there
for obvious reasons when we tried in the
first half of the last century it was
the most horrible episode in human
history the Nazi the Soviet Union no the
Democracy going out of the window I mean
it
Auschwitz I mean we we have created the
most horrific
possible nightmares that Humanity has
ever seen so on this not so well so
established body of democracy which has
one one missing and the other one we
there's a lot of work to be done we can
do a better job reinforcing a sense of
individual projects what we call not
more selfish interest yes
and no instead of no either or instead
of weakening it reinforcing it and
balancing it with a social project the
idea that no if you get together you can
do so much more and so much better than
just by yourself final example if that
car and I've used that more than once
forgive me but if that card doesn't
start
it's totally pointless for you to go and
push and come back home and say I've
done my duty
it has to be the five of us and it has
to be the five of us one two three push
coordinated so we need to have a society
that increases the support for
individual projects and that's a good
liberal democracy and counter balances
that with social common projects so that
we have both now normally you find this
a little bit more sort of developed in
no uh Western social democracies of a
Scandinavian kind
no wonder everybody wants to get there
I think I think he would agree I mean
Chomsky spoke to this but that you know
Market forces as well as technological
forces re-ontologize us and I want to
pick up on this word reontologize I
think it's an amazing word I'm just
going to scroll down to this but yeah
you you said that um once digital
immigrants like us are replaced by
digital natives like our children the
immigration will become complete and
future Generations will
increasingly feel deprived excluded
handicapped or poor whenever they're
disconnected from the infosphere like
fish out of the water you said that
information and communication
Technologies are re-ontologizing which
is an even more extreme form of
re-engineering us in our society which
is to say it's intrinsic nature is being
transformed he said that we're modifying
our everyday perspectives on the
ultimate nature of reality that is our
metaphysics from a materialistic one uh
you know in which physical objects and
processes play a key role to an
informational one so um
let's I mean you know explain your
rationale but I love this word
reontologizing yeah well this uh comes
from uh a very kanchan anti-metaphysical
perspective I uh I find any metaphysics
of the bed kind that Kant was talking
about
beyond my comprehension it's it's not
something that I just don't quite get I
mean how people can possibly believe
that they have a direct line with being
capital B and being told by being what
it's like to be being I it's beyond me
so I'm afraid on that front uh I am
rather deaf and I understand that it
might be my limitation I'd rather speak
sorry when I when I use the word
metaphysics that's what I mean the
kantian kind of thing that you don't do
because they it's meaningless to do it
there's also a lot of no kind of uh uh
Vienna Circle kind of an analytic
philosophy in in all this but ontology
on the other hand is how we um
structure the world in the sense that
we think that that's the way it is so um
with the kind of ice we have and the
kind of light around the world those are
the colors we perceive
to me the colors in the world are part
of the ontology of the world they're not
got nothing to do with the physics it's
not the way things are in themselves no
woman and Etc
I have no sense uh what we're talking
about but she's certainly a world full
of colors uh is the world which I take
it to be the world that's my ontology
now re-antologizing means changing some
of that
particular nature allow me a
distinctions are the hope is not too
confusing
reality in itself called its system
description of reality as we perceive it
enjoy it conceptualize it live through
model of the system ontology to me is
the ontology of the model it's not the
metaphysics of the system I hope I
haven't uh you know made a complete mess
here okay so metaphysics no minimum
system whatever the source of the data
that we get fantastic the data don't
speak about the source the music of the
radio is not about the radio but there
is a radio of course the music is what
we perceive the music has his own
ontology structure Etc the model the
model is at that point what we enjoy why
digit the digital revolution has changed
the the nature of the world around us
not metaphysically but ontologically so
they re-antologize because some of the
things that we have innated from
modernity
and I really mean modernity in the
ordinary sense no no three or four
centuries depending on whether you have
a large short medium modernity from
Columbus onwards or big shorteners for
first world your size your preference
but modernity we have been entered from
modernity a sense of the world that
is now being restructured and a certain
understanding of the world so
re-epistemologizing as well of their
world
two simple examples
well then at the onwards which I know
I've used in the past
um we have
grown up with the idea that
law and territoriality are two sides of
the same coin
you can't simply separate them my place
my rules your place your rules a front
with failure onwards that's the ABC of
any legal system for a long long time
the law ends where the territory of that
particular state that issues the law
ends no at the border
so low and territory ID two sides of the
same coin or two side of the same piece
of paper you can cut one without cutting
the other of course that's that's the
ontology of the world in which I leave
welcome to cyberspace right to be
forgotten a whole debate and today we
know that actually low and
territoriality are no longer two side
the same kind of been completely
decoupled and you cannot have rules that
for example pass in Europe that apply to
a search engine that is based in the
United States and yet is only one click
away so the right to be forgotten was
not the moment when this became obvious
we were legislating about Google and
Google not complied in Europe the
complaint was like well but it's not
changing the way google.com is working
well the law doesn't apply there and of
course it was a debate and there was oh
but it has to apply everywhere in the
physical space successor so the
decoupling of the law and the today's
reality is a realtologization of that
particular space we live in a different
world we perceive the world differently
conceptually we also start thinking
differently now let me give you a small
example and a close here
uh of a re-entologizing or something we
took absolutely for granted right
if you have a taxi you have a dry a
license if you have a license you can be
a taxi driver
the two things go hand in hand and it's
illegal Etc then Uber comes and having a
car being allowed to give a lift to
someone is decoupled from having to have
the license as a taxi driver a cab
driver this decoupling has generated an
enormous amount of profit problems
issues a change in game and all of a
sudden we realize yeah those two things
were not completely you know one side of
the of the other so obviously this
uberization of the world means
decoupling things that we have taken for
granted as a single unit from modernity
or gluing together
things that we thought were completely
independent in the past last example
personal identity
for a long long time we discussed
personal identity I mean philosophically
speaking as
you like not substance so uh body what
the incarnations today if you look at
anything that our identities our data
test European legislation describes us
as data and subjects
I am my information previously the whole
previous debate is discussed in terms of
no what constitutes me as that body or
information previously is a matter of
getting my body almost so
why is this important because if you
look and I close here at the European
legislation
how did they cope with the decoupling of
space
territoriality and law by coupling
personal identity and data personal data
so that today the legislation does not
say you do as you're told because it's
my space but it says you do as you're
told because this data are the data of
the individual who is my citizen
Wherever You Are so the coupling
recoupling new legislation this is
incomprehensible unless you have this
cut and paste in mind which is the
re-antologizing reappear stemologizing
of modernity through the digi Revolution
it's a big deal
the Uber example is absolutely beautiful
and and I can place myself in a startup
and and these folks think they're being
incredibly disruptive and um what you
said is interesting we used to talk
about the mind-body dualism but now
there's almost a kind of
um identity dualism you know there's my
there's my digital identity and and and
that is becoming increasingly as you say
the only thing which matters but to to
close off this um uh re-antologizing
thing I'm not sure this might be a
little bit tangential but Heidegger
conceived of Technology as an
intermediation between us and our
environment and I think in a similar way
and uh you know it shapes the
environment as much as it shapes us back
and in a sense Reliance on technology
can make us less human which is which is
kind of what you're alluding to so is
there an instructive contrast to
Heidegger's analysis of the relationship
between humans and technology and your
own
I think I had to go was um uh onto
something when you know obviously
Technologies between us and uh and the
environment but allow me to be critical
um uh
he didn't see this uh seems to me
clearly enough
um because that description the
description of the first store that
would I like to call first all the
technology is um essentially the big
idea that between me and the tree uh the
might be say uh a sewing mechanism or
the or between uh say
um
me and uh in that particular sort of uh
Garden uh there might be a spade
but increasingly and that's the
Industrial Revolution
instead of having humanity and nature
and technology in the middle you have
Humanity technology and technology and
that's a second order technology
so we increasingly use more and more
technology to deal with other technology
and it's not in Hyde it's a second order
technology but what AI does
is to generate a third of the technology
where not between A and B and C is
technology throughout so it's a computer
controlling a robot building a car
at that point we are outside that
relationship and we can just control
check that everything goes in the right
way we are on the loophole after the
loop at that point we can array so
interpret the heideggerian negative view
of technology and say that is exactly
where you want to be
you want to be outside the May
technology nature or me technology
technology I want to be on top of
technology technology technology and see
whether that goes in the right direction
now
it's even more powerful even riskier but
with higher risks higher rewards it
could also mean how Humanity they can
actually take care of the world nature
and itself properly that we would not be
able to save no this planet and
ourselves from ourselves on this planet
without technology it's inconceivable
that now we can see at the you know the
end of the 21st century as a success by
abandoning technology like seriously no
more embedded technology but then we
need to understand this now third order
idea if we're still stuck in a sort of
19th century 19th century idea that it's
between me and the world we're not going
to get out this
final Point obviously being on the loop
or after the loop the designer of of the
whole Loop comes with an Ohm's
responsibilities that's why ultimately
to me it's not digital Innovation but
it's the governance of the digital
that makes the whole difference digital
Innovation is it's
not easy but it's not difficult
especially if you have Deep Pockets you
buy the next startup in the next no
three kids who come up with a fantastic
idea knowing what to do with that that
takes a genius
so um you said in your information book
that John Wheeler coined the notion of
it from bit and some physicists
entertain an information-based
description of reality and you said that
this informational metaphysics may but
does not have to endorse a more
controversial view of the physical
universe as a gigantic digital computer
According to which Dynamic processes are
some kind of transitions in
computational states in the style
described similarly by Putnam and or you
might call it turing machine
functionalism and so you pointed out the
the ontological difference between
imagining a stomach as if it were a
computer versus holding that the stomach
is actually a computer you said that
there's a clear philosophical
distinction between whether the physical
Universe might be modeled
computationally
um is is a different question to whether
the ultimate nature of the physical
Universe might actually be digital and
computational in itself so so what's
your take I think the whole problem is
Ultimate
we go back to this temptation of talking
about reality as if we were something
that we need to grasp catch portray uh
hook uh Spears
um when in fact the the way I prefer to
understand it is as
malleable understandable in a variety of
ways
um something that provides constraints
it doesn't mean that you can interpret
in any possible way but leaves room for
different kind of interpretations so if
the flow of data that come from whatever
is out there and again I'd rather be
sort of agnostic about it
can be modeled in a brighter ways one
way is to especially 21st century given
the technology we have Etc to interpret
that as you know an enormous
computational kind of uh environment
it's perfectly fine as long as we don't
think that there is a right metaphysics
is it correct ontology for the 21st
century now this is not relativism
because on the other hand
different models of the same system are
comparable depending on why you're
developing that particular model and let
me give you a completely trivial example
suppose you ask me whether that building
is the same building
that question has no real answer because
it depends on why you're asking that
question if your question is asked
because you want to have directions I'm
going to say oh yeah that's the same
building sir the same building yeah
absolutely no go there turn left no
traffic lighter but if your question is
like same function I don't know it's
completely different building it was a
school now as a hospital
next question so is it or is it not the
same that their question is the mistake
an absolute question that provides no
interface what computer scientists call
level abstraction
chosen for one particular purpose so
that I can compare whether an answer is
better than another let me crack a joke
for the philosophers who might be
listening to some
ship is it the same or it's not the same
who is asking
why because if it is the taxpayer the
tax man
you're Doom man I mean there is no way
you can play any oh I change every plan
that you're gonna pay their taxes the
same ship I don't care but if it is a
collector
that ship is worth zero you change all
the planks you must be joking it's
worthless so is it or is it not the same
depends on why you're asking that
particular question tell me why and I
can give you the answer no why in other
words no frame within which we have
chosen the interface that provides the
model of the system
not potential answer so the question is
like is the universe a computational
gigantic yes or no meaningless
is it worth modeling the universe as a
gigantic for the purpose of making sense
of our Digital Life oh yes definitely
because we are information organisms aha
so metaphysics no I meant in the 21st
century the best way of understanding
human beings today is as information
organisms last century we thought that
biologically not made much more sense a
lot of water and sprinkle all the
prevent extra and so on mechanism Deco
time Etc so
no absolute answers no relativistic
answers but relational answers the
relation between the question the
purpose and the actual answer but it
takes three not two any absolute
question absolute Miss
this is so interesting I mean I spoke
with um David Chalmers recently and
about the hard problem and there was a
thought experiment about maybe David
lives in The Matrix and one of the
Architects came down to him and he said
David you don't have the Consciousness
model installed
um we've installed it on other people
but we didn't bother installing it on
you but your philosophical zombie or
whatever and what would we need to do to
to convince you that you're in a
simulation and David said well I'm
outside the Empire State Building maybe
if you turned it upside down I'd believe
you but but to be to be clear you're
actually saying um because I'm
interested in in this kind of um
ontological distinction you're saying
that even if we did exist in a computer
simulation it wouldn't make any
difference it wouldn't
it for the same reason that it doesn't
matter whether we are uh in God's mind
as Berkeley's subjects it makes no
difference because um what you have lost
there is any traction by asking that
particular question would anything that
would provide any answer in other words
these are only sophisticated ways of
playing heads you lose Tales I win
find me a solution
you should stop engaging with these kind
of questions is the trolley problem
you should stop engaging that particular
question because there is but
philosophers love those puzzles now the
imagine the possible World in which well
as soon as anyone start talking about
imagine a possible World whatever I
reach for Michael ashnikov or something
else uh uh I I think we should really
not indulge in these kind of things not
because they are wrong but because they
are means use any real philosophy and
I'm talking about this no 20 25 30
Classics have been using
thought experiments logical
possibilities for a purpose not in
themselves you will not catch their card
trying to you know Pro solve the the
demon not malicious demon problem that
is a tool to get somewhere it's not
something worth in itself same reason
why I know the trolley problem was
developed to test a particular Theory
not as a puzzling itself same reason why
you know people are not in a matrix etc
etc
once again ask yourself
what is the purpose for this particular
question
because your purpose is a lot of mental
enjoyment chess is much better
beautiful well and we've got about two
minutes left so I guess we'll we'll have
a closing statement but maybe also you
could bring in I mean I've got a machine
learning audience so they would be
interested in in um in in digital ethics
for example and and
um what they can do to to learn more but
also many folks are interested in
getting into digital ethics and and
philosophy so what what would you say to
those people
to the machine uh machine learning
people I
I was always say like uh congratulations
you are in the right business uh but
secondly I would say um please don't
forget where where all this is going
um have a sense that
these are not just toys these are not
just a matter of competition between one
company another to have a larger Model A
faster sort of uh computer uh a slightly
you know improved Quantum something and
on and on we can go in a variety of
directions machine learning is one of
the problems but think about the impact
that they will have on Society on the
environment and on individual lives it
could be a fantastic it could really
make a difference in suffering in not
saving the environment or it could be a
total disaster so please mind your
machine learning uh and um and be a
little bit more aware of the importance
of your job
don't underestimate how crucial it is
what you're doing you are providing the
foundations for the 21st century
Information Society that is not a small
task we do that right we're gonna not be
thanked by Future Generations you we do
that wrongly future Generations may not
be even there but if they are there they
will not be grateful so please no be
careful what can be done well one of the
things that no this will end up with
self-advertisement a little bit but uh
one of the things that we are going to
do with the with new center Yale is
precisely opening the doors to all
disciplines and all practitioners
because research and development today
is done especially in AI especially
machine learning especially in digital
context enormously more within industry
than sometimes in even the top
universities so opening up having this
translational no from Blue Sky to
product and not multi-disciplinary open
idea that it's a big table out there we
need everybody around their table the
politician the lawyer the engineer the
machine learning expert the philosophy
the ethicist the social scientist Etc
everybody around the table then at that
point that I made at the beginning will
become a little bit more reasonable
doing it together
to improve the world improve the chances
of saving the environment on ourselves
can be done uh and I'm not taking some
of my actual neck out so to speak
on this
um but it's something that I truly
believe uh it's entirely up to us and we
can do this properly if we put ourselves
into it
it's been an absolute honor thank you
thank you so much thanks a lot thank you
so much